[Musique]
et s'est invitée aujourd'hui c'est vous
sabrina à 20 h salle bonjour bonjour
bienvenue sur ce plateau vous êtes
franco-américaine journaliste
réalisatrice et vous venez nous parler
d'une américaine de 53 ans qui s'appelle
maëlys ya de lucio elle est dans le
couloir de la mort au texas et pourrait
être exécuté dans 14 jours exactement le
27 avril prochain c'est à son affaire
que vous avez consacré le document qui a
changé sans doute la sienne est
peut-être la vôtre également et qui
s'appelle l'état du texas contre mélissa
pour ceux qui ne sont pas familiers de
cette affaire on va peut-être commencer
par là l'a rappelé ensemble on est en
2007 la petite fille de mel issia lucio
qui s'appelle maria qui a deux ans
retrouvée morte dans son sommeil elle a
le corps couvert d'ecchymoses exactement
donc en 2007 ils arrivent sur place et
ils trouvent une enfant
morte couverte de bleus il se dit c'est
forcément la mère est là là il n'y a
plus d' enquête à ce moment là le sort
va s'acharner contre mélissa lucio c'est
à dire que elle va être interrogé par la
police pendant pendant six heures
sans avoir possibilité d'aller aux
toilettes d'avoir un verre d'eau de quoi
que ce soit et elle qui n'a jamais en
fait eu affaire à la justice de sa vie
va se retrouver à receler un vraiment
c'est le terme
par cinq policiers armés qui vont lui
extorquer des aveux et à la toute fin
quinze minutes avant voilà bout de
quinze à vingt quinze minutes au bout de
l va finalement dire oui basse et je
suis responsable je pense que je suis
responsable et là c'est la machine qui
se referme le piège judiciaire qui se
referme sur elle on va y revenir dans un
instant pour comprendre cette affaire et
ses enjeux il faut peut-être dire
quelques éléments de la vie de cette
femme oui mais dit ça et comme beaucoup
de condamnés à mort d'ailleurs koch
toutes les cases de la victime idéale
elle et latino à les pauvres elle a trop
d'enfants elle a eu 14 enfants au total
est fatale était enceinte de jumeaux
le corps médical quand la petite fille
est morte et pendant ses interrogatoires
hellénique human toxicomanes donc
effectivement tout ça va jouer contre
elle
mais à ce jour et au moment du procès il
n'y avait aucun témoin aucun témoin
instruction à charge effectivement
parodie de procès dans un contexte
politique particulier qu'on a peut-être
pas le temps de détailler ici avec un
avocat commis d'office qui fait très peu
cas du cas pour le coup de sa cliente et
qui effectivement ne permet pas à ses
propres enfants et à ses proches de
témoigner en sa faveur et donc à la fin
de ce procès si on peut l'appeler comme
sa condamnation à mort exactement et
puis un procureur en pleine réflexion
qui va se servir du cas de médisolution
et qui est aujourd'hui lui même en
prison il à présent pour corruption pots
de vin et un avocat commis d'office qui
a été travaillé pour le procureur juste
après le procès donc évidemment tout ça
est énorme
en france et en europe il y aurait ça
sera ça poserait un vrai problème aux
états unis malgré malgré tout ça elle
est toujours dans le dans le couloir de
la mort et donc c'est un problème
l'histoire ne fait pas grand bruit
pendant des années et puis vous
commencez à vous intéresser à cette
affaire comment est ce qu'elle est
entrée dans votre vie moi je faisais un
reportage sur les femmes condamnées à
mort pour une chaîne française et puis
je j'avais prévu d'interviewer deux
femmes dans le camp de la mort du texas
une d'entre elles étaient mélissa lucio
et c'est vrai que sur le moment phase à
l'époque avait pas grand chose à dire
sur l personnes s'était intéressé à
cette histoire c'était ça semblait un
banal cas de maltraitance quoi et quand
j'arrive sur place en fait je découvre
bas tout ça c'est à dire un procureur en
prison un avocat commis d'office qui est
lui même travaillé pour le procureur
aucun des enfants qui n'a eu le droit de
témoigner à la barre qu'il leur mère
pardon a toujours été une bonne mère et
qu'elle n'a jamais exactement un de ses
fils dit même que on a on a la vidéo
filmée de l'interrogatoire quand il a 9
ans qu'il a vu sa petite soeur tombé des
escaliers mélissa lucio le dis depuis le
début et puis malgré tout ça en fait il
n'ya il n'y a rien et puis vraiment le
moment au moins je la rencontre je me
dis que vraiment il ya un problème donc
en 2020 après deux ans dans le cas de
votre documentaire sort d'abord aux
états unis vous y montrer les failles
béantes de la procédure en vient on en
parlait et puis vous apporter des
éléments à décharge
autour effectivement la question de cet
escalier dont la petite fille serait
tombé ce qu'il y aurait peut-être
provoqué un trauma crânien et donc qui
aurait pu expliquer les ecchymoses et
ensuite le décès ce qui n'a pas du tout
été mis à jour lors de la procédure et
et de l'enquète pour vous il n'y a aucun
doute à ce stade il s'agit d'une erreur
judiciaire est pour moi n'y a aucun
doute il n'y a aucun doute de toutes les
façons elle n'avait même pas eu le droit
d'avoir les spéciales des spécialistes
qui ont témoigné à son procès son procès
a été entièrement à charge elle elle n'a
eu je crois que trois personnes qui ont
témoigné en sa faveur alors les appels
depuis qu'elle a été condamnée en 2008
les appels se sont rejoint ont été
rejetées les uns après les autres en
revanche les appels du grand public à la
clémence se multiplient particulièrement
depuis que votre documentaire est sorti
kim kardashian plus récemment c'est
peut-être plus anecdotique quoique mais
aussi il ya quelques semaines encore des
élus républicains que l'on connaît
plutôt plutôt favorable à la peine de
mort ici en france il y a deux ancien
garde des sceaux qui milite aussi pour
la clémence à l'égard de miliciens lucio
il ya christiane taubira est l'homme qui
incarne ici en france l'abolition de la
peine de mort robert badinter on va
l'écouter
je demande aux autorités texanes
la vie de mélissa
agir autrement
ce serait bien sûr un ses neiges bien
sûr
l attentat à ce qu'il ya de plus sacré
et je dois le dire au terme de mon
existence une révolte tente injustice
qui déshonorait
l'état du texas il me le besoin en ce
domaine
des mots de robert badinter qui résonne
aussi parce que le débat politique est
celui qu'il est en ce moment en france
fin de la parenthèse la date d'exécution
de miliciens à l'issue a été fixée au 27
avril prochain est ce qu'il ya encore
une chance pour qu'elle n'ait pas lieu
oui oui il ya une chance parce que le
bureau des pardons doit donner un avis
favorable ou défavorable aux gouverneurs
la quasi-totalité du congrès du texas
s'est positionné contre l'exécution de
médisolution vous l'avez rappelé des
célébrités voilà s'élève il y à une
pétition qui a plus de deux cent
cinquante mille signatures sur innocence
project l'une des plus grosses
organisations pour les condamnés à tort
quelques parfaite médisolution incarne
tous les condamnés à tort qu'il y a en
ce moment aux états unis depuis
plusieurs années et donc en fait je
pense que les gens aux états unis n'en
peuvent plus c'est vraiment n'en peuvent
plus en fait de voir que quand on s'en
prend toujours aux plus pauvres en fait
on s'en prend toujours aux minorités et
il n'ya moi de mon enquête je peux le
dire qu'il n'y a personne dans le
couloir de la mort qui ne soit pas
pauvre ou qu'il fasse partie d'une
minorité pour qu'on comprenne bien les
cartes là sont dans les mains du
gouverneur du texas en c'est lui qui
peut absolument le gouverneur ou le
nouveau procureur qui hier a dit qu' il
ne
s'arrêterait pas l'exécution vous l'avez
vu il ya deux mois je crois vous l'avez
vu régulièrement bien sûr c'est c'est 4
5 dernières années donc on rappelle
qu'elle vient de passer quoi à 15 ans
dans le couloir de la mort comment est
elle comment va-t-elle mélissa était
quelqu'un qui est garde la foi et qui
qui reste quelqu'un de très calme et
très posé très positif quelque part elle
ne se laisse pas en fait allé dans le
désespoir elle a réussi à survivre
toutes ces années je ne sais pas comment
il faut dire qu'avant le film elle
n'avait
aucune visite elle n'avait elle recevait
ne recevait aucun courrier
et de ses enfants quasiment pas parce qu
en fait vu qu'elle était accusée
d'infanticide elle n'avait pas le droit
d'avoir de visite de ses enfants tant
qu'ils étaient mineurs qui ont été
placées d'ailleurs ont été placés un
petit peu partout au texas donc donc
c'était extrêmement dur pour elle et
puis du jour au lendemain le film est
sorti elle a commencé à avoir un soutien
incroyable des gens des milliers de
personnes qui lui écrivait donc en fait
elle salua donner vraiment un espoir
très très grand encore aujourd'hui elle
garde elle est morte de peur bien
évidemment mais
on va dire qu'il ya quelques semaines
quand je les confonds j'ai passé
quelques heures avec elle elle elle
restait quand même confiant et positif
ça ressemble à quoi la vie d'une femme
dans un couloir de la mort au texas
aujourd'hui eh bien ça ressemble à
l'isolément total quand on est dans le
creux de la main on est considéré comme
une des personnes les plus dangereuses
de la société tellement dangereuse qu'on
ne peut pas être avec le reste de la
population carcérale est donc allé seul
24 heures sur 24 même quand elle est
quand elle va dehors en fait en
promenade elle est seule donc comment ne
pas devenir folle dans une situation
pareille ll a réussi à en trouvant la
fois en écrivant elle écrit des poèmes
magnifique voilà elle a réussi à se dire
aussi que et c'est ce qu'elle m'a dit
que même si elle était exécuté son
affaire s'avéraient à d'autres
des poèmes qu'elle lit dans votre
documentaire c'est très touchant en
parlant de se toucher d'ailleurs les je
crois que la visite des élus
républicains il ya quelques semaines ça
a été la première fois qu'elle a été
physiquement toucher vraiment
littéralement depuis des années si les
grâces se sont rejetées on rappelle
qu'aux états unis ça peut être quelques
minutes à peine avant que l'exécution
ait lieu vous serez le 27 avril
sabrina à 27 sur place parce qu'elle
vous a demandé d'être parmi les témoins
de son exécution j'imagine que c'est une
décision qu'on prend avec
gravité à quel titre serait vous là bas
moi je serai là bas parce qu'elle me l'a
demandé elle m'a dit tu la première
personne à m'avoir cru et je veux que tu
sois avec moi et c'est vrai qu'on a
tissé des liens tellement fort de toutes
ces années que je pense vraiment enfin
je dis à personne n'a fait une enquête
comme moi j'ai fait sur toutes ces
années sur elle et
je lui dis que de toute façon je serai
avec elle jusqu'au bout et donc il n'y
avait c'est sûr que j'y serai je serai
avec elle je serai avec ses enfants et
puis on va on va espérer moi moi j'ai
moi j'y crois c'est de toute façon je
suis un peu comme ça un peu je n'arrive
pas vraiment à réaliser c'est dur de se
dire que ça peut se passer mais moi j'y
crois je crois que quelques même si ces
quelques minutes avant j'y croirai
jusqu'au bout il y à demain un
rassemblement prévu et donc demain jeudi
à paris sur le parvis de l'hôtel de
ville à 18h30 pour le comité de soutien
j'imagine que vous en serez pour ceux
qui souhaitent s'y rendre merci beaucoup
je renvoie donc à ce documentaire si
cette histoire vous intéresse qui
s'appelle l'état du texas contre mélissa
qui est disponible sur canal+ me
semble-t-il
tenez nous au courant bien sûr et on va
suivre depuis paris
cette affaire merci encore nous en
parlait ce matin dans paris direct